worüber ich sprechen wollte ist die
energiewende ein wort in aller munde
eine hohle phrase aber auch und die
these die ich hier vortragen möchte ist
energiewende ohne kernkraft ist
unmöglich
worum geht es seit die menschen mit dem
feuer umgehen und das feuer auch
entfachen können und für sich nutzbar
machen ist unsere gesamte zivilisation
auf verbrennungsprozessen gebaut alles
ist verbrennung jetzt plötzlich sagen
wir plötzlich ist seit zehn jahren seit
2011 wir müssten dekarbonisierung wir
müssten die verbrennungsprozesse beenden
dann würden wir aber auch unser leben
beenden ohne verbrennungsprozesse können
wir nicht leben welche alternativen gibt
es uns wird erzählt die sonnenenergie
und die windenergie würden die lücke
schließen das ist nicht wahr wir können
diese lücke nicht schließen wenn wir die
lücke schließen wollen und uns mit
energie versorgen also vor allem die
elektrische energie dann kommt nur die
kernkraft in frage und dieses thema
machen wir einen großen bogen es ist
verbaut die grünen haben damit
angefangen die kernenergie die
eigentlich ein technisches detail ist
eine technische frage zur ideologischen
frage aufzubauen können dahinter nicht
zurück alle anderen parteien sind ihr
gefolgt und im jahr 2011 gab es diesen
merkwürdigen beschluss aus der
kernenergie auszusteigen
einige jahre später auch aus der kohle
und nun stehen wir da und wissen nicht
mehr weiter
ja denkst du an oder soll ich du kannst
gerne ich kann anfang an also ich habe
heute einen tweet gesehen von ralf fücks
einem ehemaligen grünen politiker
langjähriger chef der
heinrich-böll-stiftung der grünen
heinrich böll stiftung und der erste
satz war rational wäre es die
atomkraftwerke noch ein paar jahre
länger laufen zu lassen da habe ich mir
gedacht was ist das eigentlich für ein
atom heuchelei die wir haben in den
umfragen sind atomkraftwerke gerade
populär wie nie weil die energiepreise
steigen da wird man in deutschland
plötzlich pragmatischer aber niemand von
den politischen parteien traut sich zu
sagen ja das wollen wir und wie gesagt
ich war auf dem deutschlandtag der
jungen und wohnen und habe mit ein paar
politikern gesprochen und das schärfste
was man da gehört hat war wir brauchen
eine ehrliche debatte über die atomkraft
habe ich gefragt na ja schön und gut und
welche position haben sie in dieser
debatte ich habe mich noch nicht
entschieden ja mein gott sagt es doch
einfach mal dass ihr das wollt fdp und
union warum traut man sich nicht
reagiert so sagen dass man das wissen ja
dann beide sagen dass sie ihre
beschlüsse von damals er rückgängig
machen wir haben eine fdp die damals
dafür gestimmt hat wir haben einen
minister röttgen gehabt wir hatten eine
große cdu-fraktion kostbar und sie saß
mitten drin und haben in wie die
lemminge um sie herum mit ja gestimmt
mit den ausstieg aus der können wir uns
das bitte erklären
ist ja kann ich es gab jetzt eine
sachliche argumentation die ist auch
richtig ist gab damals heute bin ich mir
nicht sicher es gab damals nach
fukushima weder eine gesellschaftliche
noch eine parlamentarische mehrheit für
die fortsetzung der kernenergie kein
einziges bundesland wollte mehr an der
friedlichen nutzung der kernenergie
festhalten das war schon mal tat sei
aber die wieder kamen noch ein
parteipolitisches argument dazu ist
nicht nett aber ist die wahrheit ist
eine häufige kombination es war die
hoffnung damit die landtagswahlen im
radio berg noch retten zu können seitdem
ist übrigens herr kretschmann
ministerpräsident also dass in einem
anfall von ehrlichkeit haben hat jetzt
die geplante ampel koalition in das
papier geschrieben werden neue
gaskraftwerke brauchen übergang jakub
nada wer hätte denn das gedacht weil es
nicht gehen für die kernkraftwerke die
wir jetzt noch im netz haben haben im
vergangenen jahren so viel strom
produziert wie die hälfte aller
windräder in deutschland und in
anderthalb jahren sind wir raus wenn
jetzt einer glaubt wirken denn
anderthalb jahren die zahl der windräder
um 50 prozent erhöhen das nicht von
dieser welt werden wir nie schaffen nur
ihre these ist falsch natürlich geht es
ohne heimische kernkraft wir werden
kernkraft importieren müssen gern strom
aus kernenergie wir werden strom aus
kohle verstromung importieren müssen
davon redet ja keiner die sonne scheint
nicht immer und der wind bläst nicht
immer nur es ist wunderschön zu hören
die sonne und wind schicken keine
rechnung und alle schmerzen dann aber
jetzt nochmal zu damals ich muss man
nachfragen also sie sagen die
bundesländer wollten nicht und der
wollte nicht und alle wollten aus der
kernenergie aussteigen aber warum
wollten sie das auch nein es ging damals
um die frage ob wir wir müssen an 2011
zurückgehen ob wir damals da ging es ja
nicht um ausstieg aus der kohle nein aus
der kern aus der kernenergie zum
damaligen zeitpunkt ob wir in der lage
sind die energieversorgung in
deutschland zu bezahlbaren preisen
sicherzustellen ohne nutzung der
kernenergie das wurde ja damals ist eine
expertin aufgetreten die auch heute noch
gerne als expertin genommen wird die auf
die frage wie werden sich denn die
energiepreise entwickeln experten gesagt
hat sie werden sich nur marginal erhöht
der mittlerweile haben wir die höchsten
in europa jedenfalls in der ganzen welt
weiß ich nicht jetzt geht es um ein
anderes thema jetzt sollen wir ja auch
aus der kohleverstromung aussteigen so
jetzt das also wir steigen aus der
kernenergie und aus der kohle von spende
moment sie haben damals ja das war
damals nicht wir haben damals eine frage
noch als jetzt gesagt wir steigen aus
der kernenergie aus denn wir haben ja
noch die kohle oder gas und erneuerbaren
an das ganze klima klimbim noch gar
nicht gedacht nein da sei nur minimal
inhaltlich immer klimbim war damals das
thema um das thema
sondern das thema war steigen wir
innerhalb eines zeitraums von cd elf
jahren aus der kernenergie aus und wie
können wir dann die benötigte energie
sicherstellt ist liegen daraus nicht um
die frage wann steigen wir aus der
braunkohle fried und da hatten sie
sozusagen die braun- und steinkohle im
kopf und haben gesagt ja da haben wir ja
genug und deswegen den erker und
erneuerbaren energien und das laute
rungen der erneuerbaren und drei jahre
später hat man plötzlich gesagt du auch
keine kohle mehr das muss man doch 2011
schon geahnt haben dass das dass man
auch irgendwann aus der kohle ausstellen
dann will ich nicht wissen sie ob sie
sitzen als einfacher abgeordneter
darunter umdenken da oben die wissen
mehr als du wir haben eine ahnung die du
gar nicht hass und wenn dann die
sogenannten experten kommen und sagen
das können wir alles machen ohne dann
stehen sie doch mal als einfacher
abgeordneter auf und sagen es mag sein
dass sie die tiere zur promoviert sind
aber sie haben keine ahnung ich habe
mehr an und videos wie lothar heusel wir
haben heute eine andere lage wir haben
heute die lage dass die co2 reduktion
aus überragende thema ist und selbst
wenn wir unterstellt wenn wir die
kernenergie
abschaffen und den die windenergie
verstärken dann ersetzen wir eine co2
freie energie quelle durch eine andere
co2 freie quelle und haben nichts für
das klima gewonnen heute würden wir die
entscheidung anders treffen ich kenne
nämlich länder die steine aus der
kohleverstromung aus oder aus der
kernenergie ich kenne dort nicht länder
die beides gleichzeitig wird sie haben
sie ja schon immer einmal getroffen es
gab ja schon einmal ein atomausstieg es
wird immer so ein bisschen
fällt ein bisschen herunter nämlich der
rot grünen regierung mit gerd schröder
und in diesem fall jürgen trittin und
seine damalige staatssekretär rainer
baake und bin ich ja sehr stark
kritisiert worden auch von medien aber
natürlich auch von der position damals
für die damalige opposition heißt man
sich irgendwann sogar entschieden diesen
atomausstieg rückgängig zu machen und
laufzeiten zu verlängern das hat man es
dann passiert nach fukushima
auch wenn ich sehr sehr sehr gut dass
sie auch auf die gründe hier hingewiesen
haben hat man gesagt haben nein beginn
daraus die nächste landtagswahl droht
und da wollen wir etwas retten ist was
der grund war neben der
gesellschaftlichen stimmung die es
gegeben hat immer ich sage wir hätten
diese probleme heute nicht wenn wir uns
vorzeitig auf diesen ausstieg committed
hätten und schon damit dann den einstieg
in den ausstieg frühzeitiger geordnet
gemacht hätten ein wort noch zur
kernkraft selbst es gibt viele argumente
dafür tatsächlich
klimafreundlich wenig ressourcenintensiv
der wird immer gesagt brauche es den
uranabbau aber uran ist sehr
energieintensiv man braucht also noch
ein wenig dafür man kann den atomaren
müll zum teil wieder verwenden aber wir
haben weiterhin und dass das kernelement
keine lösung für die entsorgung
plutonium bleibt mehrere tausend jahre
aktiv der schwächste radioaktiver abfall
bleibt immer noch 500 jahre aktiv und
keiner hat eine lösung wohin damit und
bis diese frage nicht geklärt ist muss
man sagen gibt es keine lösung für die
atom grafik mehrere in der modernen
nachfahren sie haben gesagt es wäre gut
gewesen damals schon auszusteigen
regierung schröder 2008 ausgestiegen
aber oder dabei zu bleiben bei dem plan
aber sie haben wir nicht gesagt wie sie
die kernenergie ersetzen wollen wir
gehen von der dekarbonisierung aus ihr
wird eine kohle mehr wie wird diese
lücke geschlossen das müssen sie
beantworten natürlich in den anfänglich
us kraftwerke sowie sie haben so ein
klein inquisitorisch die sind ja auch
bringen
moderator
fragen
eine andere machen muss also insofern
aber ganz
sicher
war die fragen zum teil ähnlich ja das
ist ja kein ersatz also siemers ist die
müssen jetzt natürlich aber natürlich
ist wasserstoff ein beispiel dafür und
man hätte sicherlich diese wasserstoff
technologie voranbringen kann grüner
wasserstoff ist einerseits also
wasserstoff der mit erneuerbaren
energien gewonnen wird
[Musik]